y si la variante omicron es menos
peligrosa que sus predecesoras y en
particular que la delta esta es la tesis
apoyada por el prestigioso imperial
college de londres y es que a pesar del
nuevo récord de contagios en reino unido
donde el miércoles se detectaron a 106
mil casos los expertos se muestran algo
optimistas para ello compararon dos
curvas la de contagios exponencial
frente a la curva de hospitalizaciones
en muy ligero aumento sus primeras
conclusiones los pacientes con la
variante omicron tienen entre un 20 y un
25% menos de probabilidades de contraer
una forma grave de la enfermedad
respecto a los que contraen la variante
delta es como un grito ficha lo que
vemos en inglaterra es que hay más
pacientes hospitalizados en lo que
llamamos camas convencionales se les da
oxígeno y no necesitan ser entubados en
cuidados intensivos y una reanimación
una tendencia que ya se observó en
sudáfrica donde detectaron un micrón por
primera vez el mes pasado a nivel local
los casos están disminuyendo
de la ola no coincidió con el aumento
significativo de muertes según otro
estudio es más probable que la nueva
variante afecte a los vacunados y a los
jóvenes poblaciones de bajo riesgo que
tienen menos probabilidades de ser
hospitalizadas que los no vacunados